hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
cell dive a robust platform for
multiplexed whole slide imaging
and single cell analysis i am jennifer
woods of labrutz and i'll be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by
lab roots and brought to you by leica
microsystems
to learn more visit
leicamicrosystems.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting
any questions you may have during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
melinda angus hill
phd lead scientist application manager
cell dive for a full biography of our
speaker
please click on the biography tab at the
top right of your screen
dr angus hill you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for the introduction i'd like
to start today
by thanking you for attending this labs
roots webinar today
where i'll focus on a scientific example
of what can be done using cell dive
the title is cell dive a robust platform
for multiplexed whole slide imaging and
single cell analysis
i did this work in collaboration with my
colleague dr prashant dampudi
a staff software engineer for cell dive
at leica
today's talk focuses on a current study
of multiple
immune relevant biomarkers used in mul
in multiplex
to probe a colon cancer tumor microarray
sample
i'll start by providing an overview of
the genetic clinical and molecular
characterization of colon cancer
and how this work helps put
immunotherapeutic successes
and also challenges into perspective
i'll also highlight future work that's
required to improve colon cancer
immunotherapy for all colon cancer
patients
while this talk is focused on colon
cancer specifically
cancer researchers in general will be
asking similar questions
depending on the current state of
research in their field
so related to cell dive i'll present
data from a colon cancer study using a
single
tumor microarray slide to probe dozens
of tissues and dozens of
biomarkers in multiplex the ability to
explore multiple biomarkers at the
single cell level
on a single tma section is very powerful
additionally we've partnered with indica
labs with their halo platform
to analyze complex biomarker expression
of the single cell level
across large tissue samples
so ultimately multiplexed single cell
biomarker expression coupled with
cellular spatial location
can provide essential information for
understanding tissue heterogeneity
and for research and development of
future therapies
sporadic colorectal cancer is a very
heterogeneous disease with subtypes that
are characterized by
specific clinical and molecular features
85 percent of all sporadic colon cancers
exhibit
chromosomal instability or sin including
chromosomal rearrangements
also loss and or gain of segments and
loss of heterozygosity
here the earliest mutation is in the apc
gene and
the canonical wind signaling pathway
followed by various additional oncogenic
mutations including changes in wrath and
the p53 tumor suppressor gene
apart from the 85 percent of colorectal
cancers that are sin
the remaining 15 percent have high micro
satellite instability phenotypes or
msi microsatellites
are regions of tandem repeats of
repetitive dna sequence
and patients with high msi colorectal
cancer
have frequent replication errors
and sporadic forms of msi tumors are
commonly exhibit raff mutations
and cpg island hypermethylation
or simp including methylation and
silencing of the mismatch repair gene
or mlh1 familial
msi cases are called lynch syndrome and
they account for five percent of all
colorectal cancer cases
in patients arbor mutations in the
mismatch repair genes mlh1 and msh2
so current standard of care uses these
tumor subtypes to stratify colon cancer
patients for therapy
but even within these molecular features
that define these subtypes
there is still significant heterogeneity
one source of that heterogeneity is the
immune
micro environment within the tumor there
is variation in whether tumors are
immune competent or whether they lack
significant immune cell infiltration
so knowledge of an immune cell status is
essential since
immunotherapy relies on the immune cells
activation within the tumor
microenvironment
for example several several
immunotherapies target the immune
checkpoint
inhibitors such as pd1 lag3 and ctla4
immunotherapy has been at the forefront
of new treatments for a variety of
cancers
for example immunotherapy is clinically
efficacious in melanoma
and also lung cancer but unfortunately
immunotherapies have only shown
benefit in a very small fraction of
colorectal cancer patients
specifically within the subset of
patients with high micro satellite
instability or msh
that i described earlier phase three
clinical trial
data from the keynote 177 trial elevated
marks kictruda in patients with
unresectable or metastatic colorectal
cancer
with high microsatellite instability or
mismatch repair deficiency
so with this trial progression-free
survival of over 50 percent was
a very significant improvement over the
conventional chemotherapies for this
late stage of disease
and so these results led to the rapid
approval of ketruta as a first-line
therapy in june of 2020.
perhaps most importantly this success
highlights the need to go beyond
common tumor genesis markers to start to
define additional biomarkers that can
help to stratify patients
that will respond to immunotherapy
for example while the ketruta study
notes efficacy in patients with mshh or
mismatch repair deficient tumors only a
small subset of patients of those
patients
show treatment benefits so stratifying
patients by msi or
mmr is is insufficient to
avoid unnecessary treatments for
patients who won't respond to the
therapy
so recent efforts aimed at developing
new methods to characterize the various
subtypes of colorectal cancer
are ongoing for example
the consensus molecular subtypes or cms
classifies colorectal cancer into four
molecular subtypes with distinct
characteristics to better identify key
therapeutic targets
and also predict therapeutic response
the cms was developed through a
consortium
and overlays molecular and clinical
features of colorectal cancer that i
described earlier
with mr with mrna expression
so importantly this comparison starts to
allow subtyping by immune cell status of
the tumor
cms2 is the canonical subtype with
epithelial correct
characteristics and activated wind
signaling including apc mutation
cms1 encompasses the high microsatellite
instability tumors that were
successfully targeted by immunotherapy
and not surprisingly they have
significant immune cell activation
cms3 subtype is epithelial with
metabolic dysregulation
and cms4 subtype demonstrates
epithelial to mesenchymal transition or
emt
stromal invasion and also angiogenesis
so while the cms system is an
improvement that may help to stratify
colon cancer patients the cms system is
not part of current clinical care
so retrospective studies of the
relevance of the cms system are ongoing
for example can cms help define subsets
of patients where treatments may be
beneficial
or can cms help identify additional
therapeutic target
targets retrospective analysis using
these cms-specific biomarkers
can help define molecular changes in a
given cms before
treatment following treatment and also
in the case of resistance to treatment
for example for immunotherapy a
collection of immune
immune cell biomarkers can help stratify
cms1
and cms4 tumors where there are
significant immune cells present
from cms2 and cms3 which are largely
considered
immune cell deserts these types of
studies are essential to define the
usefulness of the cms biomarker studies
and cms-specific therapies for future
clinical trials
and then ultimately for clinical
practice
so from the clinical perspective a
significant challenge is to identify
those patients tumors with molecular
functional
and also stromal characteristics that
are predictive of potential response
to immunotherapy and from a research
perspective the question
remains why are immunotherapies
effective
against mmr defective and msi high
metastatic tumors robust subtyping is
essential for understanding similarities
and differences between the tumors
and there's ongoing research to
understand the molecular mechanisms of
cms1 tumors that contribute
to the immunogenicity and beneficial
therapeutic response
of these patients so another question is
is it possible to render non-responsive
tumors
immune competent currently there are
clinical trials that are exploring
whether
immune checkpoint inhibitors combined
with radiotherapy or chemotherapy
may have therapeutic benefits for
non-msi
high tumors and then finally
are there biomarkers that will help
stratify patients when immunotherapy
will be effective and are there
additional biomarkers
that may be effective as an indication
for therapy
multiplexed immunofluorescence enables
researchers to define whether biomarkers
may be therapeutically relevant
so cell dive multiplexed imaging
technology allows researchers to
spatially map
biomarkers of interest on a single
tissue slide
and provides a complete map of biomarker
expression
at the single cell level multiplex
imaging can
explore features that define the tumor
microenvironment
including immune cell infiltration and
activation or inhibit
inhibition state oncogenic and metabolic
biomarkers
stromal infiltration emt vascularization
and also wound response
the cell dive multiplex imaging solution
is a multi-step
cyclical workflow for sample preparation
paraffin removal slight clearing and
antigen
retrieval they're all completed and then
followed by an initial round of
background imaging
a virtual h e image is created used
using a patented process
and a region or regions of interest are
selected
so any ffpe sample can be imaged as a
small region of interest
or the entire tissue on a slide
or as a tissue from multiple patients
that are collected and sectioned in a
tissue microarray format
the rois are then captured throughout
the remainder of the imaging cycle
for multiplexing repeated cycles of
autofluorescence imaging staining
biomarker imaging and signal
inactivation are performed
to collect millions of data points for
each biomarker
and then automated image processing and
alignment occur in the background
and then for analysis we've partnered
with indica labs using halo to visualize
segment cells extract features and also
analyze the data to determine the
abundance and localization
of specified biomarkers for
comprehensive spatial mapping
for this study we used the cell dive
solution to examine biomarker expression
across
multiple colon adenocarcinoma samples
arrayed on a single slide
or a colon cancer tumor array or tma
shown here is a cell die virtual h e of
a commercially available
coentime from pantomics this tma has
multiple endocarcinomas mucinous
adenocarcinomas
adenomas polyps and normal
normal colon samples
for this colon tma study we probed
multiple biomarkers
four per round for nine rounds for a
total of 36 biomarkers
and then dappy enables the registration
between rounds
for analysis a subset of 18 biomarkers
was used and
those are categorized as immune cell
markers tumor
markers markers essential for tissue and
cell segmentation
these are shown here in a halo image the
staining of 11
biomarkers across a tma
halo is used as an image viewer but it's
also powerful for
image analysis for classification
segmentation
and spatial analysis there are several
halo modules that were used
including the halo tma classifier
hyplex fl and spatial analysis modules
here i've zoomed in on specific cores in
the pma
halo displays self-staining across
multiple markers in colon adenoma
adenocarcinoma mucinos anticarcinoma
and normal colon
here is a zoom of each tumor core within
the tma compiled in an 8 by 12 format
and the tumor cores from the same
patient are easily identified across
pathologies
for example here highlighted in yellow
are some of the adenocarcinoma cores
from the same patient that are
qualitatively similar based on biomarker
expression
and then here boxed in red are some
adenocarcinoma cores that are
qualitatively distinct within the same
patient
and this is possibly due to intratumoral
heterogeneity
we can quantify these differences using
the tissue classification module in halo
we utilize one set of biomarkers known
to be specific for epithelial cells
and a second set of markers for defining
cells within the stroma
halo uses color and texture information
from the marker images as inputs to a
random forest algorithm
to classify tissue into different
compartments in the first column
is an image of the fluorescent whole tma
and also a zoomed image of a single
endocarcinoma core
and then in the next column halos
classified all the cores within the tma
and then the same adenocarcinoma core is
classified with masks that
represent a specific compartment with
epithelium in red
and stroma in green it's important to
note that we trained the classifier
across a few representative cores from
all of the different pathologies
and then after training the classifier
successfully classified regions in all
of the tma cores
looking closer at specific cores here
are adenocadenol carcinoma cores from
four patients
two cores per patient data analysis
revealed samples with a higher
percentage of tumor infiltrating stroma
than epithelium in the first panel
or very low levels of tumor infiltrating
stroma compared to epithelium shown in
the second panel
it's important to note that the
similarities within patients
and how patients can be clustered based
on tumor infiltrating stroma levels
is very powerful
for example here the stromal or
epithelial comportment
size was plotted against adenocarcinoma
samples
and tumors with higher stroma to
epithelial ratio are easily identified
compared to those tumors with a low
stroma to epithelial ratio
next for each core we define phenotypic
differences in single cells in the tumor
microenvironment
we analyze 29 phenotypic combinations of
six immune markers
and cd44 at the single cell level
cells are segmented based on fluorescent
markers and the data for cells that
co-express additional markers or
phenotypes
is visualized and then recorded for
downstream analysis
halo cell segmentation uses conventional
nuclear and cell size parameters
coupled with intensity from stains that
differentially mark cellular
compartments including the nuclear
cytoplasm and membrane
within the stromal and epithelial
compartments
and then halo defines each marker's
expression in every segmented cell
and cells that exhibit a specific
expression of phenotypes are visualized
along with the segmentation mask
and then the tabulated data is also
provided for downstream analysis in
other programs like
r it's hard to see here but segmented
cells with various phenotypes are
colored
differently depending on the cell
phenotype
this slide shows hierarchical clustering
of adenocarcinoma samples based on the
percent distribution as a various cell
phenotypes
this analysis enables visualization of
clusters that
exhibit similar phenotypes for example
for epithelial compartments on the left
and the stromal compartments
on the right these clusters highlight
regions with a general lack
of immune cells additionally
this analysis suggests that the key
truta immunotherapy which targets the
pd-1 pathway
may only be effective in a small subset
of samples because t
cells expressing pd1 are largely absent
from these tumors
next we can combine each cell's
phenotype with each cell's spatial
location in both the stromal and
epithelial compartments
we plot the center of each segmented
epithelial cell and overlay the cell's
position and specific phenotype for
spatial analysis
the figure on the left shows the spatial
analysis for all 96
cores and on the right are single cores
of normal
and adenocarcinoma samples here varying
symbols for phenotypes are visible and
highlight a few of the different immune
cell phenotypes
for example the location of pd1 positive
cd8
positive tumor infiltrating lymphocytes
present
in the epithelial compartment
the same analysis is shown here for
immune cell phenotypes in the stromal
compartment of the same normal and
nanocarcinoma samples
so i highlighted a few endocarcinoma
samples with cd8 positive pd-1 positive
cells in the epithelial compartments
next we will further analyze one sample
using spatial analysis
in the first panel we map cells with
these phenotypes in both the epithelial
and stromal compartments
in gray sox9 is expressed in tumor cells
we calculated proximity analysis between
tumor infiltrating cd8 positive pd-1
positive cells
and sox9 positive tumor cells and then
maps those onto the second panel's image
here cd8 positive pd-1 positive cell
cell centers are labeled magenta and are
close to the sox-9 tumor cell centers in
gray
and then finally in the last panel these
spatial distances are mapped across the
entire core
and tabulated for additional analysis
proximity analysis enables researchers
to define the position of all pd1
positive t cells relative
to tumor cells
so in summary colon cancer is a
particularly challenging disease for
immunotherapy given tumor heterogeneity
and stratification of tumors by
molecular subtype
may help define tumors where treatments
will have a therapeutic benefit and also
help to find new markers
for therapy multiplexed
immunofluorescence with cell dive
enables the imaging of multiple
biomarkers on a single slide
and then the precise image processing
allows the exploration of co-expression
of multiple biomarkers or phenotypes in
single cells
indica labs halo platform supports
visualization and analysis of cell dive
images
including robust classification and cell
segmentation algorithms
that can be combined with analysis tools
for phenotyping and spatial analysis
so taken together the cell dive solution
allows deep contextual analysis of
multiple cancer tissues
on a single slide and provides new
insights into cancer tissue
heterogeneity
so that's the end of my presentation
thank you for your time
now i'll open up for questions
thank you dr angus hill for your
informative presentation
we will now welcome dr prashanth dimpuri
to
join us for the live q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
is the choice of biomarkers a trial and
error method
so we have a validated antibody list
that's uh
part of the cell dive solution that
consists of 350 validated antibodies
that
you can purchase from vendors from
well-respected vendors these are
validated to work with the cell dive
process
so which antibodies you use from the
antibody list or whether you want to use
your own antibodies and validate them
that's all up to you
they can be chosen as as part of the
study design process
can be tested on a small batch and then
also can
then be used on larger batches so
whatever antibody you like
is purely up to you
thank you dr angus hill our next
question is
can this method be used to identify
metastases
also can it be used to identify two
different cancers in the same patient
such as both adenoma and carcinoma
lymphoma thank you
i think that's a really good question so
so perhaps you know the tma might
be a really good option for this type of
study where
these different cancer
types can be cores from these different
cancer types can be analyzed at the same
time on the same slide
but cell dive is a research only
solution but the methods that we use are
really common
immunofluorescent methods that you are
pro likely already using in the lab
so if you're able to identify metastasis
using a set of biomarkers
currently then this can also be done
using cell dive but cell dive is
powerful because in addition to that
small set of biomarkers you may be using
you can add additional biomarkers
to that so that you can explore new
questions new hypothesis driven
questions that you may be interested in
exploring
all right thank you again dr angus hill
our next question
do you have to conjugate any antibodies
or are all 350 pre-conjugated
so we do not actually supply the final
antibodies so
these are purchased from vendors um and
we we have a list of antibodies it's a
350
antibody list and in order for in order
to
do multiplexing we
we do rely on conjugation of antibodies
so
some of those are supplied as commercial
conjugates
but most can be conjugated yourself and
we supply a manual that describes this
process and the best way to conjugate
antibodies consistently
so it's really a good solution because
it enables you the flexibility
for you to choose the biomarkers that
you want to study
all right thank you again our next
question
can this method be used to identify
other cancer other than colon cancer
um
so yes so the um cell dive is not only
useful for colon cancer but it's also
useful for other types of cancers
um it also can be used just for
human disease so any time that you need
to spatially map
any sort of co-expression of different
biomarkers at the single cell level if
you're looking for any type of micro
environment cell dive can be useful
so this is useful beyond the cancer
field is that correct
yes beyond the cancer field yep perfect
thank you
and multiple types of cancer and beyond
the cancer field thank you
oh amazing thank you okay the next
question
is this based in direct or indirect
fluorescence or both
um sorry was that is it placed in
direct and indirect all one all one word
um i don't really understand that
question but um
basically the dyes are conjugated to the
antibodies so
uh we we have a linear visualization of
biomarker
expression um but i don't i'm sorry i
don't understand that question
maybe we could get clarification for
that
question yeah sure if the questioner
would like to clarify
that would be amazing or maybe your
question was answered then that's fine
too
we'll move on to the next question how
are the nuclear parameters for
segmentation adjusted for different
types of cells and tissues
hey thank you for asking that so
multiplexing i love
staining with multiple biomarkers and
any biomarkers that enable
compartmentalization of the tissue
should be included in your study design
this ensures that cells which look
different can be segmented using
different nuclear parameters
in addition we also wanted to point out
that halo's classification module
allows one to compartmentalize different
tissue types
and you can then use the hyplex module
in halo
to tune segmentation parameters for each
compartment
based on the shape and the size of
average cell in that particular
compartment
thank you dr dompori we have
a few more questions here what are the
pros and cons of staining tissue in the
tma format compared to a single tissue
format
i think that's a really good question
and it sort of is based on
your study needs so the pros for
tma staining are that
you can include positive and negative
controls on the array and then you can
also
add multiple samples from the same
patient and
also from multiple additional pace
patients
so this provides the ability to directly
compare the expression patterns
across patients and control samples
so the cons would be mostly related to
tumor heterogeneity
so the the issue
if if you have a heterogeneous tumor you
want to really be careful when you
assemble the array to make sure that you
choose the
right tumor regions or that you fully
explore
that tumor so for example um
if you have high intra-tumoral
heterogeneity where tissue cores are
vastly different from other course in
the same patient
it can contribute to irreproducibility
of results so basically your results are
not reproducible
and so you'd like to standardize the
tissue sampling across distinct areas
within that same tumor for each patient
so the also but if you did have that
issue you could combine the data from
multiple cores
to reflect the biomarker heterogeneity
in the
in that data so if tumor heterogeneity
within the tumor is a problem then you
might want to consider full
tumor sections rather than tumor course
thank you dr angus hill looks like we
have time for one more question
what kind of stainer do you use is
manual stain okay
and if so does the system have a high
quality requirement for the staining
so those are two really good questions i
think
cell dive is really flexible in that you
can
really stain the slides any way you wish
to so you can either do it on a benchtop
manually
and use a humidity chamber or you can
use
an automatic automated stainer um these
will commonly stain you know 30 slides
at a time
um or you could use a liquid handler we
have a
an open well system that that i didn't
discuss today um but
it basically allows for this for you to
wash and incubate the slide
without a cover slip and so you're able
to um
to to basically leave the slide in place
and you can go through all the slides
and washes
in place and you can either do that by
hand or you can have a liquid handling
robot that will do that
so it's really sky's the limit on the
way that you stain
the slides the second question about
does the system um can you tell whether
the staining worked with the system
we actually have quality control steps
built
in to the software so if you find that
you've stained
slides and the stain didn't work or
the staining wasn't optimal or you had
some imaging artifacts
or anything like that you can fail the
qc
fix the problem and re-image so once
you've
started the process you we have these
built-in
qcs so that you can stop if you do have
a problem and and fix the problem
thank you dr angus hill do you have any
final comments for our audience
um yeah i i really like to thank
you for this opportunity and i'd like to
thank you all for your time
if you'd like more information about
cell dive you can click on the resource
tab available on your screen
and have a nice day
well thank you again dr melinda angus
hill for your time today
and also to dr prashanth dumpuri for
joining us during the q and a
we would also like to thank labruz and
our sponsor leica microsystems for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand lab roots will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye